well hello reject nation its Greg outlet
here and I am Bethany
that's ma aka I need a star hey I don't
know what the hell bathroom a is don't
understand the reference
I need a text to me this morning did
sang pre-record residue video I like
crazy and if I ever watched a rock a
rock video without Anita oh man oh boy I
swear the conversation I hear all about
it
after the terror watch it way too it is
a real surreal argument it's real I'm
not hearted yeah yes before we go into
this I'm going to do a page shows a
shout out format viral that'll be at the
end of the videos to keep a look out
Matthew Dragonball Z vs. avatar last
airbender
I hope it's M night Shyamalan avatar and
Navi an animator that's been assessed to
an area to finding one day a year Dragon
Ball movie which is back let's do this
welcome Oh a game big ambition and did
you challenge the official I see now
what we'll do
[Music]
potato they don't work everybody to grab
something and so
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here change
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my good
[Music]
crap
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are getting hurt that they are
gendered by the end population 3 go
quality didn't make it look like they
were on a dam that was loud them I'm so
happy that record record make you look
really good I would love to be in Iraq
Iraq abhi is so bad holy crap man their
visual stop keeps getting better like it
looks like they upped it a little bit I
mean cuz that was amazing like
especially when they were in the
bathrooms of what how does the water was
sort of it at under water she had said
like has like super professional studio
ha yeah I mean there's no way they're
not like super pro yeah there's only so
far you can do just on your own yeah
because I know that but a long time
their sketches were just with their
buddies damn seeing all that I mean the
amount of wall they were thrashing
through like in a row yeah record record
is always either disturbing or inspiring
yeah there's one of the two emotions
that generator Bing Lee inspired yeah
one of those it could be that one as
well I've never seen that black guy
before
no how about my favorite they have a lot
of like people they're just random in
their videos like even in the classroom
when the students were different some
like these people yeah they actually had
background yeah I'm in the hospital with
the right right tons of background but
yeah then where do they shoot like how
do they get these awesome set or do you
think they're real locations enema
campus that has to be genome like
warehouse yeah I think they shot that
every destroy that be amount of water
were thrashing and explosions ever going
on I mean I kind of missed the old days
when it was just these violent sketches
inside of their house they were all
living at Lee I missed that I do like
another Harry Potter versus Star Wars
you but this is still really cool there
are upping their sink as a
that one was that the Naruto showdown
with another homage to an anime and
having their own washes here that's
really cool that they have an awesome
hyper blend because they're not just
playing the characters they're playing
like versions of themselves as the
characters yeah and speaking of the
homage to the animes and such I think
it's great that they the transformation
took so long because I didn't know I
wasn't dragonballs when you're audited
you're just like come on man whatever
when Joe could have really been beat to
death good of it but I loved how quickly
the end of that me and Joe they didn't
like really drag it out but you they
love make understand Sonic's or catch on
yeah really seen the enemy you know and
the inner dialogue thing that they did
yeah whereas I loved that it was like
yes the little touches and then and like
in the hand like oh yeah those little
things make it really work they just
like really hit yet if you're a thing
you did a wreck or a guy saying crazy
and crazy 8's and if you're ever in
California I guess love for you to
thrash my apartment thrash yeah a lot of
stir about all the carbon on over there
I'll pay for all damages and everything
as long as I can make it the Cameo
honestly just a cameo even if it looks
like rip my eyeballs out quick yeah one
line in the background I be more than
okay with that and say I pay money to
make your own yeah I could pay thousands
of dollars they out this page and
surprising and merged I'm first oh yeah
my expertise yeah February I don't shirt
it to her shirt or jacket that'd be cool
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the rack of reckon ater now you can
subscribe to the real rejects put the
knitted a handout breathe in I need a
stargazer is on the Anita star channel
go check that out a lot of fun videos on
my there yes so much fun hey Chad a
shout out Matt Lyles
Wow Matt Matthew is the name of one of
the books in the Bible
okay easily the worst book in the Bible
I haven't read the Bible I've read it
when I start burning and no as they
should
yes they do the Matthews is not ace is
not powerful B is poorly written lack
and narrative they could have used more
it's very straightforward yeah that's
what I hear and it's just like another
story from the point of about Jesus I'm
like hum I got three other books should
I tell away better keep Jesus Jesus all
right
yeah that so suddenly yes sir yeah
the Matt miles I'm sorry you were named
after easily the worst one in the Bible
shout out patrons disarmed Matt